[Musique]
on a déjà vu des cas mais l'île auprès
de la vie si tous qu'on est astucieux
belle
johnny fait le plus sérieux à familles
ont préféré kalala au casino de la forêt
à si tu veux tu crois oui bien sûr qu'on
est vraiment au point ah oui ça tu
chantes déjà maintenant ce qui est vrai
c'est que tu puisse jouer d'un
instrument de musique a alors je me suis
âgée nier attentes trouver atteint
fabriqués à a voilà tu vas voir c'est
très joli
tu vois ce tube c'est ça s'efface d'un
prêt en plus c'est facile à construire
un pont pour tout le monde
oui tu pas un tube oui tu coupes une
partie de ce tube alors attends c'est un
c'est un tube en métal tube voilà tubes
en métal
alors on coupe le bout le bund un bond à
lui et à l'autre bout tu fais des
petites roues sur le côté 1 autour et un
plus gros trou dans milieu oui tu as
fait quatre petites roues oui oui et
puis alors un goodwill milieu vitamines
paille aussi alors tu introduis une page
oui tu coupes à un pas grand hugo a
failli oui et puis alors qu'il ya et
c'est tu vas tu souffres là dedans
et alors tu vas voir le joli saut que ça
donne ah c'est quoi ça fait comme une
trompette
on ne peut pas dire c'est très beau
c'est alors cerceau et le vertueux oui
souffle fort
attention mais enfin qu'est ce que c'est
que ça federico mais qu'est ce que tu
m'as fait là dedans je suis plein de
farine tu ouvres ouvre tu verras parce
que j'ai mis un bouchon heures et puis
de la farine des liens bouchons et de la
farine dedans bah moi je joue plus 15
ans atteint par est à noter jeunes
jouerait plus avec ce genre de choses
s'y amuse au nom de cet amusant angad
moi ça va essuyer dans le jardin bon
fallait de la rosée est lamentable enfin
t'as pas honte on voit mon stylo rôle à
la fois comme un serpent vrai jeu
fabre est allé trop va continuer sur
nous lance et il faut le mettre à genoux
la mi séance
la bri oui ben y en a il est vrai fâché
je pense qu'on entend un peu partout sur
mon bon poulet bah oui faut donc la
halakha évidemment je suis très belle et
sombre je prends un malaise de la sarine
partout alors dit je sais pas si tu vas
y arriver parce que en tout cas il ya un
point commun entre nous trois oui en ce
qui me concerne je crois que je vais
t'étonner car ce que je suis aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment un rôle de composition
ah oui imagine-toi par exemple que je
suis quelqu'un qui a mis toute petite
voix alors qu'en réalité tu sais bien
que je pourrais chanter des grands
opéras en plein air tu vois des choses
alors aujourd'hui je suis en ces
chanteurs très confidentiel de qu'on
entend à peine et comptera tendrait même
pas du tout s'il n'y avait pas de micro
tu vois ma voix est vraiment et bien ici
c'est un rôle de composition que je vais
tenir aujourd'hui je suis en effet une
simple ménagère qui va faire son marché
tous les matins moi qui déteste porter
le moindre paquet off pour toi j'ai fait
un effort et je me faufile entre les
cages aux choux fleurs les
amoncellements de l'aquilon par ci une
livre et demi par là et je rentre chez
moi chargé comme un baudet ou du mais
quel métier
moi je suis un pécheur je n'ai pas pas
un pêcheur à la ligne
le petit pêcheur du dimanche celui qui
vient poser son petit pliant aux bords
au ban de lola au pied d'un arbre mais
qui attend patiemment que ça morde
non non je suis je suis un vrai marin
mais vrai marin qui s'en va avec son
chalutier et qui reste quelques fois
absent plusieurs jours été comme hiver
par tous les temps alors j'affronte les
maires j'affronte les maires pour ta
portée des sols des sardines du colin du
hareng et caetera et c'est alors tout
quand est un chanteur tu n'as pas
beaucoup de voix si j'ai bien
oui les choses comme ça oui toi bell
bell tu fais une ménagère oui c'est un
marché des compositions ainsi bien
compris bien sûr
quant à pouss me sucer un grand classeur
devant l'éternel oui c'est ça est ce que
est ce que vous avez trouvé le voir une
petite idée dans cette affaire là
si je résume bien alors que vous avez
voulu le battre à ce jeu je vais
résoudre l'énigme
je crois je crois qu'on pourrait dire de
tout cancan qu'il aurait un filet de
voix on peut réduire de bell bell
laquelle à filet à provisions et qu'on
pourrait dire de pouce moussu killam 1
s'il est un filet de pêche tout ça
vraiment terrible alors qui est le plus
fou alors qui est le plus de voix je
vous laisse oui oui je vais préparer le
même jeu que tu connais oui fabrice
geniez colonnes 11e round
bon on pousse pousse eu oui oui vous su
mais au fond le oui oui à la main tant
fabrice ça c'est à nous et à nous deux
cette fois ci je lai abbas est
formidable ou alors tu vas au tableau
alors je te propose un mot en huile être
mais alors la première oui la première
c'est un n même comme noémie iba
premières lettres 1 mm et la dernière or
1er mai à fortifier les petits les
petits traits titrait alors que tu m'as
dit combien de lettres je fais si petit
trait c'est ça la ccl exactement 2 3 4 5
6 et je termine avec la lettre r non
mais sûr de toi oui oui où j'en suis sûr
je suis sûr bon bah nous allons voir
alors je t'écoute
serait ce une fleur
non c'est pas une fleur dans ça m'embête
ça serait ce un animal aux non non non
pas un animal reste une plante riche et
une grosse une grosse un arbre voilà
c'est ça c'est un vrai talent à un petit
alors un petit arbre un petit élevé est
ce que tu veux que je te donne une
lettre encore pour t'aider oui parce que
là la quatrième à lesterps la 4e à la
quatrième c'est un sms c'est un petit
arbre tu as détruit
oui oui oui oui oui faut les cas c'est
faux les cas c'est un homme attend vous
faire intentions d'ailleurs dans les cas
moi j'en trouve un tas trouver j'en
trouve un mais avec neuf lettres
comment fait on ne sait peut-être pas le
mien alors c'est peut-être pas non mais
tu me dis des fruits qu'on casse oui moi
je pense aux droits des noirs je pense
aux noix astier 1 bat à trouver ma
chicha le noisetier pas comment le
noisetier ah oui tout quand tu te rends
compte
regarde comment ils et comment tu écris
noisetier ben aux ist i er noisetiers
c'est comme ça que tu écris noisetier
ben oui le set up se mesure pas mais
c'est invraisemblable mais en cinq mois
astier nous on sait que ça s'écrit comme
ça l eau s all incapable d i et r
noisetiers à dangereux mon genre mais ce
tableau qui gère trois places bawa la
base valable
e o o l'incapable tier-1 noisetiers en
danger mon genre mais ce tableau qu'il
ya trois places voilà bastien la
prochaine fois je ferai attention 10 à
chaque fois puis même est unanime à 10
mois fabrice oui tu sais que lés
noisetiers porte aussi un autre nom on
les appelle aussi coudrier c'est vrai
oui c'est vrai koudrine et oui il ya des
gens avec une baguette de coudrier ou de
noisetier il arrive à savoir où trouver
de l'eau oui oui il ya de l'eau et celle
des sourciers exactement à l'appel ces
gens là des sources qui mais j'en ai vu
passer souvent à côté de moi dans les
petits chemins comme ça ils tenaient
leur baguette de venteux et quelquefois
up la baguette s'inclinait vers le sol
et en creusant au trouvait de l'eau
voilà c'est un titre ordinaire dans
cette inde dont ils font ça et [ __ ]
baguette comme ça pue théorie de l'os et
oui et tu le savais où j'allais savez
savez ça devient dangereux
mais alors tout cas encore qu'est ce que
tu me proposes maintenant moi j'irai
voir ben je sais pas pourquoi mais moi
j'irai droit soit appliqué à jouer avec
moi
c'est pas si la musique tibétains des
personnes dont un bébé saloum la cen sad
auraient alors moins cher favori oui tu
le veux bien pour rester dans la note
rigole c'est très drôle que je dis là ne
remonte pas à l'homme mais le jouer à
notre petit jeu
oui tu sais qu'il faut que tu complète
mes phrases mes mots avec les noms des
notes de musique doremi face à la speedo
on pourrait passer à la machine à café
du pont du monde pourrait mettre dedans
ma chérie je voulais maîtrisiens je
voudrais que nous regardions encore une
fois tous ensemble
la gamme parce que tu sais mais tu sais
les enfants ils ont vite compris leemans
a quand même été un peu lent mais
regarde do ré mi fa sol la si do en clé
de sol le pilote admettre que les lits
un oui c'est alors aujourd'hui je te
propose de parler voyage
bon tu veux venir avec moi si tu veux
qu'on avale 11 y veillons choisissons
l'europe l'asie à l'amérique
si nous allions en amérique flâner sur
les bords du talent à la vie quand je
dis ah là là cela veut dire que tu dois
me remplacer ce travail avec deux
manettes wii alors que vu que nous
allions flâner sur les bords du nil à la
main et monte là alors moi je dirais mis
6 6 me et ben voilà on y est très bien
je lui dis moi comme nous allons voyager
à ces lois et parfois dans des contrées
perdues et nous nous irons sans
itinéraire sans carte
il serait peut-être bon que tu prennes
une boue
une bon goût une brousse solde via
semaine servira quand je n'ai aucun sens
de l'orientation
ni de la géographie dix mois est-ce que
c'est aux bords du mississipi qu'on
rencontre des cowboys qui attrape le
bétail avec un blanc seau aucun doute à
la place de boue alors ça va ça c'est
facile ça regarde pas tous sur les bords
du lac da nau du lac n'est pas cette
fois ci que c'est une erreur
dan si si si si c'est pas une erreur
alors que nous allons aussi aller dans
les grands ports de marseille du havre
ou alors de bord de bord oui oui de bord
mais si je le dis dans l'effort de bon
là où ce qu'on a on y va de bord
bordeaux bordeaux aussi de ton côté tu
as des désirs particuliers je te suivrai
web rituels et où j'aimerais mais moi
oui
formé au psg en date oui alors attends
au pays deux honda on paye déjà
j'entends brusquement comme des voix we
see me dire elle a appris à peu près 1
je te ferai le pays de jana je te dirais
bon et si de ton côté tu as des désirs
particuliers je te suivrai ou aimerais
tu allais où généralement oui oui oui
alors attends au pays de zondag on paye
déjà non brusquement comme des voix oui
qui me dirait un peu à peu près je te
ferai le pays de jeanne d'arc
je te dirais tu vas voir ça comme ça ça
me sens et ça comme ça doremi bon ça
peut tout à fait dorer fait don réunion
révèle dans l'attenté que l'on peut
jouer alors c'était bien
j'ai pas mal content de ce dernier la 3
elle y abri nous avons bien joué
oui on a chanté nous allons chanter
maintenant oui sommes d'accord les
étapes déjà papa pas aidé à me dire qu'à
nous la reverrons du peuple la vie
désiste mais je chope se déchausse mais
comme juni pas de minois livre on a fait
attention les cadres ni comparativement
à 10 mai qu'axa me sens heureux d'arisem
amis
oui
[Musique]
il a joué aujourd'hui a dit vouloir
devenir amis
[Musique]